you know you know already i didn't even
really think it was we're making a movie
it's no surprise that we are thrilled to
see batman return to the screen and with
the positive reviews coming in by the
truckloads we're curious to see what
made the magic happen so pull out those
batarangs and get ready for the
behind-the-scenes scoop of what really
went into the filming of matt reeves the
batman
number one it's apparent that any actor
who plays batman will need to hit the
gym at some point in their life training
is a lot more it's a lot more fun when
you kind of get good at it this was the
case for when robert pattinson took on
the reins of this character and he
really did quite enjoy the workout
process for a while he was put on an
intense diet and training regimen before
and during the filming process but only
after six weeks he got a little sick of
it once you pass over the six week mark
then then it's all right it's got to be
difficult drastically switching up your
diet and routine for a film but he did
take it seriously and it turned out
pretty good for him in the end as
director matt reeves really wanted him
prepared shirtless for the trailers
number two pattinson always had an
affinity for style but his most recent
fashion statement included a suitcase
full of comic books i was traveling with
stacks of batman comics reeve's story
embodied the batman comics and their
noir nature which prompted robert to
head to his nearest comic book shop he
found so many of them that he liked and
of course that fit within the director's
vision that he apparently needed a whole
suitcase to fit them in andy's been
doing this since 2019. that's a lot of
reading i think i must have read just so
many number three some of the cast
didn't need to go far from their homes
for filming the batman in fact a lot of
the shooting was done in the uk the
sense of realism filmmakers wanted to
make for their set pushed them to more
gotham-like architecture and at least
for pattinson and colin farrell they
were home sweet home of course they gave
a break to some of the american actors
when they filmed at the california sound
stages
number four every time a new trailer
came out we got to see a new look at the
extravagant set designs by production
designer james chinlund and the cast was
just as mesmerized i've never seen
gotham look so so much of a character it
kind of felt like stepping into a
different world every time cast members
and crew went to work and even helped
form a lot of the great performances we
get to see as they wanted to create the
most realistic looks for the film they
chose a lot of landmarks throughout the
uk but the real world came in when they
built the interiors at soundstages in
california wayne manor in particular was
so convincing that it just set the tone
for the whole idea of the production
design aspect
number five the covet 19 pandemic rocked
the world along with the hollywood
industry shutting down mid-productions
and causing mass uncertainty for matt
reeves he was almost in the middle of
filming his movie and they ended up
having to shut down for months but they
finally got to return putting baldano to
work first since his scenes were more
isolated dano really didn't have a
problem with this and the ball started
rolling for production again
unfortunately however production came to
a halt yet again when batman himself got
coveted we remember being uncertain as
to whether robert's sickness was going
to affect the film's future but have no
fear because they pushed on and the film
was finally finished
number six along with pattinson catwoman
actress zoe kravitz had a lot of
legacies to look up to for her iconic
role the same thing they did which is
you know own it own it but she wanted to
only take a few aspects of their
characters and push far away from all
the catwoman stereotypes not only did
she make a big point of this when
developing her character but she only
wanted to make selena kyle as human as
possible and of course still weave in a
little feline aspects in as well
number 7 this one doesn't surprise us
all that much considering penguin's
makeup design from the trailer even kept
us guessing as to who it was the cast
and crew were pretty dumbfounded when
colin farrell arrived on set in his
penguin prosthetics that even zoe was
not accepting it it was probably
farrell's brilliant acting and amazing
makeup that just convinced her that it
couldn't be him and she wasn't the only
one jim gordon actor jeffrey wright had
a few words about his initial look of
colin i walked right past him farrell
ate this up and always took advantage of
his new look and even got a leg up on
the acting method with the prosthetics
number eight it's hard to kick off an
intense action film with a flirty fight
pattinson and zoe both had some issues
selling the brawl how to do like a
flirty punch
though it's very common that a film
shoot lineup mixes the scenes around so
what was the problem they were just
thrown into the scene the first day of
filming not that they didn't have
rehearsals though they were able to
rehearse the fight a little with their
respective stunt doubles and each other
of course all it took was the right
flirty punch and now they were truly the
bat and cat in action
number nine sometimes parents can
overstate their child's achievements and
even though zoe kravitz earned such a
legendary role her father may have told
his friends about the wrong movie dad
it's it's the batman
lenny kravitz was uber excited to tell
all of his friends and family that his
daughter was the star of not the batman
but of the catwoman so cute that her dad
is showing the love but poor kravitz
felt a little parental embarrassment
when it leaked to the press
number 10 wearing a heavy costume
delivering lines and fighting under hot
lights is enough to make anyone exert
themselves which was directly in between
it would drop directly between those
eyes once robert initially put on the
costume he felt so much power and
thought he could do anything but when he
actually had to physically fight in it
the sweat started to rain down on his
co-stars it really got kravitz when they
started filming the more intimate
fighting scenes but she knew how much it
bothered robert and that they simply
just couldn't get around that number 11
we know that this realistic take of the
batman means that everything has to be
real and robert really has to get close
to a real-life bat in one of the scenes
that's one of the strangely difficult
scenes as batman follows riddler's clues
he comes across a cage with a message
that is guarded by a bat maybe bruce
wayne was facing his biggest fear but
fortunately for pattinson he kind of
likes the little creatures the only hard
part for him was trying to wedge his big
suit arm into the cage they looked so
awkward
number 12 there were so many cool
aspects from the trailers we got to see
but one of the most chilling by far was
that cryptic letter from riddler to
batman sometimes actors are able to make
their own props paul dano actually did
try to write his own letters and they
were promptly dismissed no i think we
tried my handwriting
uh dana recalls it as more of a team
effort between himself and the crew but
we think he should just trust reeves
judgment on this one number 13 it's been
said amongst cinematographers that
effectively lighting the bat suit is the
biggest achievement and who couldn't
have done it better than cinematographer
greg frazier who had already achieved
lighting star wars darth vader but this
was a process he was not ready for and
took days to finally achieve the look he
works really above and beyond to do what
he does
number 14 you have to give a little show
and tell when you get that perfect
makeover and collins penguin really
wanted to show off with an oat milk
latte not that i was awesome a big
drinker but he does have his dose of a
sweet tooth during initial makeup design
he snuck off to his local starbucks to
get a very unlikely villain drink
ordering in that gotham crime lord
accent was more than enough to get looks
from other customers but he obviously
enjoyed every minute of it and really
needed that coffee
number 15 out of all the possibilities
in the universe carmine valgoni actor
john tutturo has a son who works for dc
comics and of course he turned to his
son for advice and approval giving him
all the necessary inside info to prepare
for the character and when he was asked
if his son liked his final performance
thumbs up yes i'm relieved and very
happy so yeah there was a lot of hard
work that was put into the making of the
batman and also a lot of funny moments
with the cast and crew so now that we
got some inside info behind the scenes
are you ready to finally see it in
theaters what is your favorite onset
moment that you are excited to see play
out in the final film
leave a comment below